you already know that we can view
multiplication as repeated addition so
if we had two times three we could
literally view this as three twos being
added together so it could be two plus
two plus two notice this is one two
three twos and when you when you add
those twos you get six what we're going
to introduce you to in this video is the
idea of repeated multiplication a new
operation that really can be viewed as
repeated multiplication and that's the
operation of taking an exponent exponent
and it sounds very fancy but we'll see
with a few examples that it's not too
bad so now let's take the idea of 2 2 to
the third power which is how we would
let me write this down in the
appropriate colors so 2 to the third
power so you might be tempted to say hey
maybe this is 2 times 3 which would be 6
but remember I just said this is
repeated multiplication so if I have 2
to the third power this literally means
multiplying three twos so this would be
equal to this would be equal to not 2
plus 2 plus 2 but 2 times I'll use a
little dot for multiplication 2 times 2
times 2
well what's 2 times 2 times 2 well that
is equal to 8 so that is equal to 8 so 2
to the third power is equal to 8 let's
try a few more examples here what is
what is 3 what is 3 to the 2nd power
going to be equal to
I don't you think about that for a
second I encourage you to pause the
video so let's think it through this
literally means multiplying two two
threes so let's multiply three let me do
that in yellow color let's multiply
three times three so this is going to be
equal to 9 let's do a few more examples
what is
what is say five to the let's say five
to the fourth power and what you'll see
here is this number is going to get
large very very very fast so five to the
fourth power is going to be equal to
multiplying 4 5 so 5 times 5 times 5
times 5 notice we have 1 2 3 4 5 s and
we are multiplying them we're not adding
it this is not 5 times 4 this is not 20
this is 5 times 5 times 5 times 5 so
what is this going to be well 5 times 5
is 25 25 times 5 is 125 125 times 5 is
625